what up space fam golson here from anime
outbroad back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one punch man story we get to see king's
true power and full display a new
strongest monster emerges even stronger
than golden s and more so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do enjoy
these one punch man chapter reviews then
channel the cape baldy within and
serious punch that like button with no
mercy remember that smashing that like
button is sight to my energy while
passing is pure ugly energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to get your regular
dose of one punch man content and lastly
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my one punch
man playlist that includes videos on all
the s-class heroes all dragon and god
level monsters and much more link to
that is in the description now without
further ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all on the cover page we got what
looks like psychos looking very fine and
the narrator says that woman gets more
beautiful clad and evil and yeah can't
argue that she's looking gorgeous here
yet another example of what it does
talent for illustration and why the
manga is worth reading even if you're
caught up with the original web comic
back to king though and the king engine
king stepped in and now we get to see
the consequences of him doing so we're
told that the king engine usually is a
symbol of terror that signifies certain
death to monsters but the dragon level
monsters of the monster association have
absolute faith in the power they possess
it was merely a shot of adrenaline that
they felt to set their fighting spirits
ablaze as we'll see this narration is
sacrificing accuracy for humor but it's
part of what makes one punch man so fun
there's always this epic setup before
hilarious things ensue of course king is
just worried in his head about dying all
this time but from the outside the
dragon level monsters keep
misunderstanding him and by the way it's
interesting that they're called dragon
level here black s was already dragon
level and here it's implying that golden
s is dragon level 2 even though he is
way stronger so they really seem to be
stretching dragon level here to
encompass a very
very large variety of power i always
like focusing on this stuff because it
can be pretty arbitrary so it's
important to know how the manga is
presenting it as i said before the exact
definition of god level threat is a
threat to the survival of humanity and
if you don't count saitama and
exceptional heroes like blast atomic
samurai with the sunblade then someone
like golden s could definitely be a huge
threat but if you count saitama as part
of humanity then we won't actually ever
have an official god level threat
because no one can beat him so it's
interesting to think about how
classifications can and should work in
one punch man golden s says king is
waiting for them to make the first move
they wonder how king even fights but
homeless emperor hilariously answers
that he has no idea out of all the
heroes king is the only one with an
abnormal lack of battle data we know
this is because he doesn't actually do
the battling but they assume it's
because he's so next level homeless
emperor says he's very good at
manipulating information he seems to be
touted as the strongest man for a reason
the wild stories about king circulate
among them like that hostages are
useless because king can make monsters
lose consciousness without even touching
them homeless emperor decides to test
out king's power and he is confident
enough at first he fires up a huge
attack and king's stoic face remains
impenetrable as his mind is exploding in
warrior when told he'd be vaporized if
touched by the giant energy sphere he
simply says okay seemingly channeling
the greatness of saitama here in that
response just as homeless emperor is
going to attack and win it king
interrupts him saying wait haven't you
noticed yet king then tells him to look
under his feet shocked homeless emperor
looks down and doesn't know what he's
looking at it's clear though that he's
begun to lose his confident edge he's
sweating now and easily surprised king
goes on to say confident on the outside
all those little chunks of rubble are
pretty unstable it's dangerous it looked
like you hadn't noticed so i figured i
should tell you end quote
what is actually random and desperate
talk comes across as the ultimate mind
game he appears to be flexing hard on
his opponent even going out of his way
to worry about him when he's trying to
kill king homeless emperor hilariously
convinces himself that he has to read
between the lines now he's breaking out
in sweats and thinking that king is
actually warning him that he can dodge
the light sphere and be on top of
homeless emperor in an instant and that
there is no way he could escape while
he's standing on that rock as a result
he halts the attack and even considers
himself lucky that he found out what was
going on before it was too late he is
sure that if he attacked king would have
found an opening for sure and killed him
there's an excellent panel where a giant
king looms over homeless emperor to give
us a sense of how he's feeling he
proclaims he'll show everyone the real
king today and king starts worrying
internally about whether he knows that
king is just a regular human he
accidentally says just a regular human
and instead of giving himself away
homeless emperor is shocked he
interprets the words as saying that king
knows his secret that if you take away
his life powers then he is just on par
with an average human now homeless
emperor is worried that the black s's
and golden s will find out and then
he'll be in trouble just as he's going
to rush to finish king before he reveals
any more below his feet zombie man
emerges he pins down homeless emperor
and taunts him to try attacking him now
because they're so close homeless
emperor will suffer the damage too he's
got him cornered now and this is that
king power insane levels of good luck
when he needs it whether it's saitama
coming to aid him at the right time
people interpreting his actions and
words in the most convenient way
possible or a hero like zombie man
emerging in the nick of time he's able
to get out of every battle looking like
a beast while internally freaking out
all the while you don't see something
like this as much in other shonen series
and when you do it rarely lasts as long
as it does for king but it's a recurring
thing in one punch man even against the
strongest opponents and i always find it
hilarious unlike with hercule in dragon
ball the strong villains actually think
king is a beast rather than just random
humans and that fresh detail makes it
that much more funny when homeless
emperor is begging for help the black
s's ask why would they risk leaving
themselves open to attacks in front of
the king they are ultra cautious and
even though they have over 50 trillion
cells they say it's not like they have
unlimited sell stock and to be fair a
lot of those cells are in goldenness
right now then evil nature water takes
center stage for a second and he's not
moving it's supposed to be a creature
who responds to hostile emotions and
attacks but obviously king is too busy
being afraid to have hostile emotions so
he's not setting it off of course
blackest assumes that in the blink of an
eye king saw through its ability and
stopped his killing intent in their view
king is able to hide his emotions
completely from them like he was facing
an ant rather than a dragon level
monster black s is freaking out but
decides to stop him while child emperor
has a plan to push all the monsters in
one place so that king can deal with
them in one attack king overhears this
and continues to freak out himself
knowing he could do no such thing we see
a funny illustration then of what people
think king is capable of it's very
telling and it seems like a parody of
the super saiyan form as king is shown
going super sparkling king mode ssk and
about to use his limited time secret
killer move it's pretty much a glorified
kamehameha and can annihilate all of
these dragon level monsters from
existence in one go it goes to show that
even the heroes have no idea what to
expect from king and let their
imaginations and the rumors run wild
then something crazy happens but it was
a popular theory for a while so it
shouldn't be too surprising if you've
been watching the chapter reviews the
remaining
11.449 trillion black s's proceed to
fuse with the 43 trillion in golden s to
form a fusion of about 54 trillion black
s's it was like 10 trillion to form
golden s in the web comic and there was
no form beyond that so this is a huge
deal right here in the manga it's
hilarious how much confidence child
emperor has in king and actually views
this as a godsend since they will be
easier to take out in one body we are
told that 100 cells did detach for
insurance but these aren't really a
threat on their own one goes on to face
metal bat he cries and we get some very
webcomic inspired illustrations he is
crying for the 54 trillion of him losing
their individual consciousness and lets
us know that once merged there is no
more separation but the sacrifice of all
these will lead to a precious and
beautiful new life there is sadness as
so many disappear into nothingness and
happiness for the debut of the quote
unquote true me as black ass puts it in
the meantime king is being told to use
the special move and of course he's just
standing there because he can't knowing
this series though they're probably
interpreting this as him being curious
to see someone that could approach even
a fraction of his power metal bat takes
care of the crying black s or at least
that's the implication and we see a very
cool and unique design for the new form
of the s's platinum s and that is the
end of this epic and even more so
hilarious chapter after the golden s arm
was cut off i did mention the last
review that he'd regrow it by absorbing
more s's and possibly become platinum s
and that is exactly what happened here i
love to see it and it's just crazy power
scaling wise goldenest already seemed so
above the other dragon monsters present
here and now platinum s will take it to
a whole other level can't wait to see
how they handle this they may never call
him god level officially since he isn't
a threat to saitama but man this is so
much more than just dragon can't wait to
see his power in action and to see how
king handles the situation is there
finally a monster that won't be afraid
of king or like usual will he start
freaking out after over analyzing king's
behavior hopefully saitama will make his
appearance before too long but yeah that
is it for this one let me know what you
thought of it as usual and what you
expect to happen in the next chapter who
was your mvp this time around i think
king is the obvious choice he stepped up
knowing he could be killed at any moment
and it bought enough time for zombie man
to take down homeless emperor and force
the asses to fuse into this new epic
form if you did enjoy this review and
want to keep the reviews coming then
channel the capability within and
serious punch that like button with no
mercy remember that smashing that like
button is slight to my energy while
passing his fear or ugly energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to get your regular
dose of one punch man content and lastly
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my one punch
man playlist that includes videos on all
s-class heroes all dragon and god level
monsters and much more link to that is
in the description and i especially want
to thank the patron squad over on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost i want to thank the patron
of legend the one acknowledged by lord
twigo himself alpha sigma and other one
to your patrons the ones who stand on
top all clans ingrata al jatal pate the
red haired fox hinokami and water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the spike
dylan isadore spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis big buddhist monkey d
quilly cody hebert and jeremy cummings
and our pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
joanne garcia fat boy games kaido might
be a duck jessica rabbit and jeremy
phillips thank you all so much if you're
also a fan who enjoys our work you can
directly support more of it by going
over to patreon.com animeapro and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course the dank memes
so check out patreon.com anime upload
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button that
you've hopefully already destroyed so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you